- We're back with the stars
of the new Netflix movie,
"The School for Good and Evil"
Kerry Washington, Sofia Wylie,
Sophia Anne Caruso, and Charlize Theron.
Give it up!
(crowd cheers)
- So if there's one sure fire way,
cause I say sure fire a lot,
so we thought we'd put that in the script.
If there's one sure fire way to settle
a dispute between good and evil,
obviously it's a dance off.
That's what we're doing here.
So it's time for another round of
Dance Battle Double Down.
♪ Dance Battle Double Down ♪
- We've got uneven numbers,
so here to even us out
please welcome the director of the film,
Paul Feig!
[Upbeat Music]
- Yeah, we've got you back on.
- Thank you.
- Now get over there.
- Okay.
- Okay, now let's meet our host!
You saw him in the movie, "Bros,"
and you'll see him again
in the upcoming season of
the hit show, "Hacks," on HBO
Here's Guy Branum!
- Yay!
- Nice to see you.
I'm running, I'm running, I'm running.
- Thank you for having me back, Kelly.
- Yes!
- Hi Guy.
- We love you.
- Hey Paul.
- How are you?
- You guys this, is a dance game.
Okay, dancing for the good team,
we have Kerry Washington,
Sofia Wylie, and Paul Feig.
Dancing for the evil team,
We have Sophia Anne Caruso,
Charlize, and Kelly.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- The good team is playing for
the good people in the audience,
and the evil team playing
for the evil people in the audience.
- [Clarkson] Yes.
- [Branum] The winners
will win a very big prize
for their side, so get excited.
- [Washington] Okay.
- [Feig] Yeah.
- [Clarkson] No pressure.
- All right, here's how the game works.
I'll read a question,
the answer to the question
is the name of a dance.
If you know the dance,
jump up on your platform and shout it out.
If you're right, you'll
have a chance to double down
for another point by doing the dance.
- [Clarkson] Okay.
- If you're wrong, or you can't dance
the other team will have
the chance to steal.
All right, are you guys ready?
- [Feig] Yeah.
- [Wylie] Yes.
- [Branum] Are you guys ready?
- Totally!
- [Branum] All right,
we're gonna play in rounds.
First up, we got comedy
legend, Paul Feig versus Kelly.
- Oh boy.
- Oh.
(crowd cheering)
- Wait, are we allowed
to step on this step?
- Yes, step up on there.
- Okay. Okay. Okay.
- [Branum] Kelly and Paul.
- [Clarkson] Yeah.
- [Branum] Here's the question.
- [Clarkson] Okay.
- As kids in the summer, we
used to like to put this item
out on the lawn and run through it.
- [Theron] Yes!
- Kelly Clarkson?
- The Sprinkler!
- two for Clarkson.
- Can I get a little sprinkler for you?
From you?
- Yeah. Here we go.
Can I hit it?
Oh.
- Oh my gosh.
- A death drop.
A death drop from Paul Feig.
- High deserve.
- You don't need to come
for me Kerry Washington.
I was going to give you a point anyway.
- Okay, thank you.
- We got two points for
evil, one point for good.
Kerry Washington and Sophia
Ann Caruso. You're Up.
- Come on. Come on.
- You got this. You got this.
[Crowd Cheers]
- All right.
- Okay.
- Here's your question.
You might get annoyed at your dentist
because every time you
go in for a cleaning
they remind you to do what?
- Oh
- Kerry Washington?
- Floss.
- We have Olivia Pope Flossing for us,
Ladies and Gentlemen.
One point for the answer
One point for the dance,
One point for being legendary.
- Yeah!
- Four Points.
- For team good.
I'm sorry, Sophia Ann
- I gotta be honest with
you, I didn't know that one.
I didn't.
- Charize and Sophia Wiley
Lets get up here, it's your turn.
- Okay, come on Charlize, come on.
- Yeah, Come on Evil!
- All right.
[Charlize]- I'm Ready.
- This cartoon character was
framed for the disappearance
of his girlfriend, Jessica.
Charlize Theron.
- Oh, Rabbit.
Roger Rabbit.
- I think you might have had some help
Charlize Theron, but Char-
- Because I have the best
team because I have the best-
- Charlize Theron.
Can we see Roger Rabbit?
Let's get some music.
- That's it right?
That's how we.
- You have different
nineties Hip-Hop dancing
In South Africa, I assume.
- That's how, Yeah
That's how we do in South Africa.
- Can you steal, Do you
know how to Roger Rabbit?
- I Think so?
- Okay.
[Hip-Hop Instrumentals]
- Oh!
- Yes.
- That is one more point.
The evil team up to three.
- You Know what?
Evil's allowed to cheat.
- We didn't need that point.
- What?
- All right.
Alright, Kelly and Paul,
you guys are up again.
Let's do this.
- Okay, Come on, come on.
- We got this
- Come one Good, We got this Good.
- Next question.
It's hard work on your booty
to do this dance that
also rhymes with work.
- Oh, Oh.
- Oh.
- Go Feig.
- The twerk!
- All right, yeah
- One Point.
[Dancing Music Playing]
- He's my favorite person ever.
- Congratulations. Good Team.
- That also means the Good
side of the audience wins
but as you find there's
little good and evil
in each of us so
everyone's a winner today.
- Because Kerry, Sophia and Paul beat us,
Their photos will be hung
with the highest honor
on The Chicks Wall of Champs
who beat Kelly Clarkson.
- Um, Not many have made it to that wall,
but Paul, congratulations.
I think you did single handedly win
with your twerk.
You, your twerk brought it home, brother.
A big thanks to Guy Branum
for hosting everybody.
You can see Guy in the movie, Bros
as well as in the new season of 'Hacks'
coming soon to HBO.